tu sais que quand elle t'a quitté quand
elle est tombée enceinte du pain de de
l'homme
ainsi jean soûlât petit garçon ils
s'appellent les eaux
il a presque sera quand elle est revenue
avec le petit et elle a laissé c'est
l'adresse de son école déposé une lettre
d'amour dans mon casier et à chacun de
vous la bouche succès ma nuit je signe
ça c'est clairement que j'étais petit
c'est des jouets de garçons
[Musique]
je me sois en plus je crois
et à des enfants cette école au nom de
chaque campagne juste le fils d'une amie
déménagement est prévu pour quand on
vacances de la toussaint défi que les
humains avec tous agissent maintenant je
devrais pas mais tes pieds dans le plat
mais trouve qu'à une sorte de tension
sexuelle prônant
je peux être ange d'habitude c'est juste
un vrai souci passagers tu sais pas tout
ce qu'elle représentait pour lui ta mère
ta fatigue même recette fall je sais
qu'il a des difficultés pour remonter la
pente mais il avance suis pas fou à
corte pas je suis lutte contre toi maman
c'est difficile de savoir écrite
ça fait longtemps qu'il est malheureux
alors il s'isole
[Musique]
tu m'intéresses à voir
sourire tout ça m'intéresse
je veux pas arrêter de faire comme s'il
n'y avait rien qui me touche et c'est
pas vrai l'appareil
[Musique]